yeah what's what song you want sexy r on
you want me to play it sure play it play
it right now all is it out no mo excl
exclusive exclusive there's a couple of
rap girls that I
that date that you a
date would you date uh Connie I just
play who's Connie she on a song with her
H Diamond mhm oh no nice G nice game I
got to ask yeah you guys have a nice
little drill [__] relationship going
you know yo this [__]
is hey she's fire she came up here and
freestyle she's hard that's all right
Play the song man we need the exclusive
that's game that's
game it's called Craner you are you know
what a Craner is of course not no no
[__] said of course not a Craner a
Craner you ever got crane crane is head
a Craner is instead of Dome come here on
the dick [__] be [__] or what like
I'm trying to show you a
trick her lips come here let me get in
your lip and the sex always start with a
kiss what are you dumb the sex always
start with a [__]
kiss you never [__] a [__] without
kissing her oh no those a hoes the hoes
I don't kiss the hoes gangster you know
who told me to kiss the hoes F my maer
bro bro yo n Go put me on the bad game
what about D yo bro I'm Mii I'm Miami
bro I'm like 14 years old I'm like yo y
I'm about to go link this [__] what
should I do you're 14 huh I'm like what
should I do he got to be like yo you
just got to be like yo let me get a kiss
I did that the [__] looked at me like I
was [__] stupid yeah she should have
also you shouldn't be kissing the horse
that's how you end up with the that's
how you end up with some [__] on your
lip that's got some [__] on its lip yo
[__] violated me bro don't say
that yo bro just stop y
like don't say
that don't say
that nobody violated you you're fine
you'll be all
right try to leave me the wrong way so
so now I need to tell my wife I want
some crane crane crane what is it Craner
but your wife is going to smack you bro
I don't you should tell your wife what
[Applause]
crane the Kramer no wait what is it the
Craner bro the Craner right
so your wife though your wife yo yo
these guys I was kicking with them today
said I need some crane some Cranium from
you
bro you know little
Cranium
yeah y bro so the EP you guys have no
idea anything about your what songs you
know when n's coming out no all right
I'm keep with you yeah you know October
it's October not say no stupid [__] on
here bro cuz he about to just start
going viral about to say the whole [__]
y so it's coming out in November no
hey watch out you're going to break my
[__] light back there Kyle this is
fire bro sh
3D it is there in real
life oh thre
dimensional it's definitely not 2D
everything is 3D hey hey technically
word everything
word word word you shrooms yet I love
shrooms
any bad trips it depends like for me
heard them should Elevate you move so
you take them while you s so you see the
guy over there
filming no
okay stop so yo so he did a that's Cyrus
so Cyrus did a bunch shs last night
right how much he
took enough to keep him up till six in
the morning [__] tripping balls and
tripping balls and I I get a 14 a.m.
text from Cyrus and it says I love you
bro and I appreciate you more than you
know a i KN you was probably mad he was
mad happy as soon as I was like oh he
was shrooming last night H yeah that's a
real shroomed out like I'm i' like have
you ever like told people how much you
appreciate them cuz you're bro when I
take shrooms bro my happiness mad happy
yo J I really love you my heart yo n it
really be it really be laughing for like
30 minutes straight like I just un what
we just be laughing at
nothing oh what the [__] is other sh I'm
not
on I'm not on that put a t on your wait
what you put a what a tab it's like a
little acid tab or you could put it like
in your hat isn't it like a strip in
your hat in your hat and a sweats in
your forehead sweats in your forehead n
y'all [__] get you now you putting me
on what's that
it you like what is it bro very visual
High what you mean visual High
visual you start seeing things that's
kind of dangerous
though
M better
now yo yo yo is that better all right
yeah so you do acid and then you see
things how wait how long is the how
depends on how much you do so they got
these like acid uh spray like they put a
tab in like a spray and you like almost
like banaka like mint spray he just hit
it it's fun n
[__] it's a lot of fun what it's honestly
it's fun [__] it it's a great especially
if you go to a concert like if you go
see Playboy cardi you going to see the
devil you're going see Satan on
stage you be like what's up why why is
why is there a vamp oh you know yeah no
you guys should I would I would not tell
you to try many drugs but try
acid I only do rooms perks and hey hey
hey I don't even do perks y'all should
not be doing perks I like perks perks
are terrible I like do you why why the
perks I like perks they make me feel
regular that don't make sense gangster
hey perks are bad okay only one how B do
what do you mean how let me know it's a
bad drug they're very addictive n i
don't get addicted cuz I promise you
I'll take them just probably like not
all the time unless you get surgery then
you do the perk
I don't need surgery it's pain
management and I go through a lot of
pain I'm trying to show you okay have
you ever had sex on a
perk I heard it's a bro a perk it makes
your sex Everlasting so does so does
Viagra oh no Viagra you going crazy I
mean you ever had you ever took a honey
pack of
course right to the face what they work
nah oh my
gosh hey honey pack solid we be putting
on the look
you tried that no no no put it in the
Hennessy put that [__] in the Hennessy
that [__] is going to have you
bent the honey will have me bent I just
do the honey pack straight up by itself
I don't need the [__] don't do thatjust
no
[Music]
more have you guys ever done the uh the
the the the gas station Rhino pills like
the Blue Rhino not to gas station to die
I if you go to the liquor store RH pill
well it's the same [__] as a honey pack
it's just it is no it's not [__] that
[__] is unhealthy you going to die bro a
honey P you're taking
peret no but that [__]
is pill
you when you guys know you're going to
[__] a bad [__] for the first time do
you do a honey pack just so you impr
press knock it out the park and home run
no oh you guys are so young you guys
shouldn't be doing this y right up was
spy yeah that's for Old Men a rhino pill
yes yeah I'm
36 this the thing if you're drinking
right all right so how do Rhino pill
like work like it's like it's so look
this way I look at it if you're going to
get drunk right you got to have
reinforcements so you don't have whiskey
dick so if you're going to drink a lot
you want to perform yo bro [__] be
saying that that feel me they don't feel
me can turn on by a [__] and they [__]
be your feel me n as soon as I see the
[__] I'm mudy bro not fact you're muddy
muddy Oh I thought you said you was
muddy I'm like what does that mean bro
tell me please what that's lingo too
what about that mudy yeah that's another
lingo like yo as soon as I see a [__]
[__] my pants
bro it's real money get real
money I Chuck the
de yeah but you've never had whiskey
dick where you drink too much and then
you're like hey you know I can't come no
no what hell
no yeah yo what the maybe it's an old
guy thing I don't know I got too drunk
before like I just sat on the [__] face
with the sleep what you sat on her face
n sit like sit in the bit like we talk I
like I'm just s her face to and we go to
sleep like not even [__] you sat on her
face you sat in her face in her face
like we just chilling
like does that mean that never happened
to you you have a you had a [__] come
over you too drunk y just go to sleep
I've never sat on a girl's face no I
don't sit on a girl n hey yo bro stop
bro yo stop bro I've never sat interface
either hey yo